* Ruhige, idyllische Klänge *
Los jetzt. Komm, komm.
Hü.
Hopp.
Geht rüber.
Ihr folgt schön dem Schatten, wie?
Die Idylle auf diesen Thurgauer
Weiden könnte einen einladen,
über die beschaulichen Seiten des
Lebens auf dem Lande zu berichten.
Über den Biobauern Markus Ramser
z.B.,
der gerne Neues ausprobiert
und von der Milchwirtschaft
und vom Ackerbau lebt.
Doch dieser Film erzählt, wie
dieser Bauer zusammen mit seiner Frau
für seine Überzeugungen einsteht.
Und wie es ihm dabei ergeht.
Begonnen hat alles vor drei Jahren,
als das Bauernehepaar
einen eritreischen Flüchtling
zu sich holte.
(Frau) Tesfu!
Also Tesfu, das ist dein Baum.
Dein Schweizer Baum.
- Ja.
Der Bund und der Bauernverband hatten
ein Integrationsprojekt lanciert
und dafür Bauern gesucht.
Vorher hatte ich immer Lehrlinge.
Dann dachte ich,
das wäre was für mich,
weil ich weiss, dass ich
mit solchen Leuten umgehen kann.
Und ...
... das ganze Flüchtlingswesen hat
mich auch irgendwie etwas belastet.
Sie ... sind in den umliegenden
Gemeinden und stehen rum.
Es ist doch schade, wenn sie keine
Arbeit, keine Beschäftigung haben.
Und Leute brauchen wir im Betrieb.
Ich habe mich mal gemeldet.
Und dann hat das geklappt.
Jetzt ist noch zunehmender Mond.
Mond.
Für alles,
was in die Höhe wächst.
Jetzt ist günstige Pflanzzeit.
Magst du keine Steine?
Doch, gut, aber ...
Das nimmt alle Nährstoffe weg.
Weisst du,
jetzt wächst das Gras weniger.
Ich war schon auch dafür.
Man soll den Menschen,
die als Flüchtlinge hierher kommen,
auch eine Chance geben soll,
hier zu sein.
Wenn sie
wirklich arbeiten wollen,
sollen sie auch
die Möglichkeit dazu bekommen.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Und bei jenen,
die nicht arbeiten wollen,
bin ich auch der Meinung, dass
man sie wieder wegschicken soll.
Weil Chancen auch immer
an Erwartungen gebunden sind,
besteht immer auch die Möglichkeit,
dass etwas schief geht.
Niemand weiss zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
ob diese Geschichte,
die so idyllisch anmutet,
ein gutes Ende nehmen wird.
* Ruhige, idyllische Klänge *
Tesfu hat keine Ausbildung.
Nach der Schule
wurde er wie viele Eritreer
in den Militärdienst eingezogen.
2012 kam er in die Schweiz.
Drei Jahre lang lebte er im Asylheim.
An einem Schnuppertag
fürs Integrationsprojekt
hat Markus
den 31-Jährigen kennengelernt.
Und als dieser
die B-Bewilligung bekam,
hat er ihn bei sich eingestellt.
Er ist direkt aus der Gemeinde
ins Erwerbsleben eingestiegen.
Er erkennt auch, wie die Arbeit ...
Er sieht es.
Das ist wichtig.
Wie etwas gemacht werden muss.
Weil Tesfu gut arbeitet, hat Markus
einen ehrgeizigen Plan mit ihm.
Er will ihm
eine richtige Ausbildung ermöglichen
und hat ihn vor einem Jahr
für die zweijährige Anlehre
als Landwirt angemeldet.
Die Schule hat eine Ausnahme
gemacht und ihn aufgenommen.
Am Anfang war es streng,
aber jetzt ist es gut.
Jetzt habe ...
... ist schon ein Jahr vorbei.
Jetzt noch mal ein Jahr.
Markus und Emmi halfen Tesfu zudem,
seine Frau aus Eritrea nachzuholen.
Seit drei Monaten
ist nun auch Merhawit in der Schweiz.
Nur:
Das junge Paar kennt sich kaum.
Wie in Eritrea üblich, wurden die
beiden von ihren Eltern verheiratet.
Doch das ist schon acht Jahre her.
Merhawit, willst du mitfahren?
Nein.
* Er spricht tigrinisch. *
Das heisst Fahrrad oder Velo.
Auf tigrinisch, Tesfu?
* Er spricht tigrinisch. *
Nicht bicicletti.
Bicicletta, ja.
- Ja.
Er hat damals, bevor er ging,
nehme ich an,
in Eritrea geheiratet.
Einfach kirchlich.
Sie muss 14 Jahre alt gewesen sein.
Vorher dürfen sie nicht heiraten.
Ich nehme an, dass er danach ging.
Er blieb schon immer
in Kontakt mit ihr.
So gut es ging - die Verbindungen
stehen ja nicht immer.
Und sie ist dann ...
Also ...
Er musste sie
einfach noch offiziell heiraten,
damit sie in die Schweiz kommen
konnte. Für den Familiennachzug.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ich bin noch nicht ganz überzeugt.
Sie dürfte etwas mehr ...
Da dürfte mehr sein.
Ich habe das Gefühl, er hat ...
Er leidet ein bisschen.
Er hat halt ...
Er kennt unsere ...
... Situation in der Schweiz
bereits.
Und ...
... er kann jetzt nicht 1:1 umset-
zen, dass sie auch alles mitmacht.
Aber ich glaube, das wird schon.
Aber es ist ... hart für ihn.
Das merkt man manchmal.
Denn sie will noch nicht alles,
was er will.
Diejenigen, die frisch kommen,
haben halt zu Beginn riesige Mühe.
Nicht nur für Tesfu und Merhawit
ist alles neu.
Auch Markus und Emmi Ramser
ahnen nicht,
auf welches Abenteuer
sie sich eingelassen haben.
Sie haben Merhawit sehr offen
in ihre Familie aufgenommen.
Die eigenen vier Kinder
sind erwachsen,
nur die behinderte Tochter Susanne
lebt noch zu Hause.
Die obersten ...
... 16 Reihen Kartoffeln,
die haben brutal trocken.
Die obersten.
Unten dran ist dann gut.
- Wo? Beim Bändchen hinten?
Ja. Ganz trocken.
- Und nächste Woche regnet's nicht.
Eben, nochmals eine Woche nicht.
- Nein, es war ja ...
Am Morgen war es lustig, da mähte
niemand, aber jetzt fangen sie an.
Jetzt gehen sie trotzdem.
Markus ist 68.
Einer seiner Söhne
wird den Hof übernehmen.
Bis es soweit ist, möchte er Tesfu
als Hauptarbeitskraft nachziehen
und selbst ein bisschen kürzertreten.
* Tigrinya *
Kommst du auch?
- Ja.
Tesfu ist römisch-katholisch,
wie die Hälfte der eritreischen
Flüchtlinge in der Schweiz.
Früh verlor er seine Mutter,
wuchs mit seiner Schwester
und seinem Vater auf.
Seine Geschichte
gleicht der vieler Landsleute:
Militärdienst, Flucht nach Libyen,
Betrug durch Schlepper,
Inhaftierung
in libyschen Gefängnissen.
Bis er von seiner Schwester,
die es vor ihm in die Schweiz
geschafft hatte, nachgeholt wurde.
Es sind zwei Welten, die auf
diesem Bauernhof aufeinandertreffen.
Unterschiedlicher
könnten Tesfu und Markus nicht sein.
Und doch haben sie sich gefunden.
Kannst es runterlassen.
Ich habe Vertrauen in ihn. Aber
man musste es ihm auch schenken.
Es ist auch gegenseitig.
Emmi nimmt Merhawit
unter ihre Fittiche,
um sie mit dem Leben in der Schweiz
ein bisschen vertraut zu machen.
Ramsers haben ein weiteres Haus
auf ihrem Grundstück.
Dort haben sie das junge Paar in ei-
ner Dreizimmerwohnung untergebracht.
Emmi hat für Merhawit
gleich daneben
einen Flecken Erde
für einen eigenen Garten vorbereitet.
Du weisst wie?
Merhawit, Merhawit!
So.
Weisst du, du musst schön gerade.
Merhawit, nicht so. Schön gerade.
Sie macht es gut.
Sie kommt mehr ...
Doch, doch, sie ... wird offener,
zeigt jetzt auch
etwas mehr Interesse,
auch wenn sie beim Kochen hilft.
Doch, sie kommt schon
hinter dem Busch hervor.
Es ist für sie in der Schweiz
natürlich etwas ganz anderes.
Eine andere Kultur,
ein anderes Leben.
Aber ...
man muss sie einfach etwas
aus ihrem Schneckenhaus rausholen.
Tesfu, komm.
Du musst uns etwas zeigen.
Hier und hier.
Sie muss hier setzen ...
... und hier und hier.
- Lassen, kein Problem.
Und wo sollen wir ...
Wir haben ja so viel.
Wie weit auseinander? Hier?
- Einfach so machen.
Nein, mach mit ...
Auch für Tesfu hat sich
mit Merhawits Ankunft viel verändert.
* Merhawit spricht tigrinisch. *
- Nicht zu tief.
Vorher verbrachte er
seine ganze Freizeit mit Freunden
aus der römisch-katholischen
Kirchgemeinde in St. Gallen.
Letzten Samstag, als er
den Zug nahm, sagte er,
er müsse mal wieder weg.
Er müsse weg.
Er brauche wieder mal seine Ruhe.
Dann ist sie halt am Samstag
und Sonntag alleine,
was ich nicht ganz begreifen kann.
Dieses Wochenende ging sie mit.
Er ging Fussball und Volleyball
spielen. Sie schaute ihm zu.
Er sagte, vielleicht
fange sie auch mit Volleyball an.
In St. Gallen gibt es
eine Gruppe Eritreer, die spielt.
Es kommt.
Markus baut auf 32 ha Gemüse an.
Es ist Frühling, die Kartoffeln
müssen ausgesät werden.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Wenn viel zu tun ist,
hilft Markus' jüngster Sohn mit.
Und natürlich auch Tochter Susanne.
Und weil Markus die Integration
von Flüchtlingen ein Anliegen ist,
beschäftigt er nun für die kurzen
Einsätze nicht mehr Osteuropäer,
sondern ausschliesslich Eritreer.
Die 31-jährige Rava wohnt zusammen
mit sechs anderen Flüchtlingen
im Asylheim
der Nachbargemeinde Müllheim.
Wir hatten immer Leute.
Jetzt haben wir
es einfach mal probiert.
Er war auch eine Herausforderung,
mal mit and...
mit fremden Menschen zu arbeiten.
Aber es ist
voll und ganz aufgegangen.
V.a. ist es schön zu sehen,
dass es ihnen Freude bereitet.
Diese Menschen machen eben alles.
Alle Arbeiten, die unsere Schweizer
nicht mehr so gerne erledigen.
Rava
ist seit vier Jahren in der Schweiz.
Sie hat immer noch den Status F
als vorläufig Aufgenommene,
doch seit 2017
dürfen auch diese Leute arbeiten.
Sie wünscht sich sehnlichst ...
Sie sucht seit gut
einem halben Jahr Arbeit. Aber ...
Ich wollte ihr zuweisen,
weil ich weiss, dass sie gut ist.
Aber es ist für sie sehr schwierig,
dass die Leute sie nehmen.
Gut machst du das, Susanne.
Gut machst du das.
Hast du es nicht gesehen?
- Doch, doch.
Du musst rufen.
Hey.
Ist es schon lange leer?
- Ja.
Wie viele Kartoffeln hatte es, wenn
zwei oben waren? Immer nur eine?
Ja.
Oder zwei?
- Nur eine.
Meistens nur eine?
- Ja.
Gut. Muss immer, wenn ...
- Nur eine ist besser, oder?
Ja. Bei zwei
musst du sagen: "Schneller fahren!"
Dann macht die Maschine so.
Dann geht sie weg.
Weil auch Rava ihre Sache gut macht,
hat Markus beschlossen,
sie fest anzustellen.
Obwohl er damit das Risiko eingeht,
sie bald wieder zu verlieren.
Wenn dort unten plötzlich
gute Verhältnisse herrschen,
sind das natürlich die ersten,
die zurückgehen müssen.
Aber wenn sie Arbeit hat, werden
sie sie nicht direkt wegschicken.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Markus stellt sich vor,
dass Rava bei Tesfu und Merhawit
im oberen Stock wohnen könnte.
So würden sich die beiden Frauen
gegenseitig unterstützen.
Ja. Ist gut?
Birne.
Es ist einfach schöner,
diese Beziehung.
Es lebt, wenn man
die Leute direkt bei sich hat.
Das Vertrauen und alles - es
ist einfach ein anderes Verhältnis.
Du kannst dieses Zimmer haben.
Ja.
Hier ist bereits ein Bett.
Und der Schrank gehört auch uns.
Das Bett auch.
- Mhm.
Hier hast du ein Bad.
Okay. Das ist gut.
Wenn du ... bei Papa arbeitest,
hast du hier das Zimmer.
Okay.
Okay?
- Das ist gut.
Kannst du ...
- Danke.
Wenn Rava Arbeit hätte
und Geld verdienen würde,
fiele sie dem Staat
nicht mehr zur Last.
Markus ärgert sich, dass man
den Flüchtlingen in der Schweiz
wenig Anreiz zum Arbeiten gebe.
Wer arbeiten will,
soll doch eingesetzt werden.
Und zwar so schnell wie möglich.
Denn das mit den Geldern ...
Es stört mich,
wenn sie zu viel bekommen,
ohne dass sie etwas leisten müssen.
Arbeit haben wir.
Die steht zur Verfügung.
Wenn wir sie ihnen nicht geben,
sind wir selber schuld.
Dann müssen wir halt ...
Dann müssen wir für die arbeiten.
Für ihre Sozialleistungen.
Dessen müssen wir uns bewusst sein.
Tesfu bekommt von Markus
3'500 Fr. im Monat,
abzüglich Kost und Logis.
Das ist ein voller Lohn,
obwohl Tesfu noch in der Lehre ist.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Kalt, es war sehr kalt.
Hier ist auch Frost, siehst du?
Das ist nicht voll ausgebildet.
Die Spitze ist abgefroren.
Hier fehlen eins, zwei, drei.
Drei Kerne fehlen.
- Ja.
Das wirkt sich am Schluss
auf den Ertrag aus.
Er ist ja Lehrling,
also Auszubildender.
Dann muss man ihm
diese Sachen halt auch beibringen.
Das, was sie aus der Schule kennen,
was sie dort lernen,
das geht so schnell, das
müssen wir ihnen in der Zwischenzeit
immer wieder ...
... sagen,
damit es sich setzen kann.
Ja.
Das ist
eigentlich unsere Aufgabe.
Wenn ich etwas
nicht verstanden habe,
dann schreibe ich es auf.
Dann sagt
oder erklärt es mir Papa.
Das ist unsere Aufgabe.
Aufgaben, ja. Aber es geht schon.
Ja, ja.
Mhm.
Beim Deutsch
muss er schon noch gewaltig zulegen.
Aber es wurde nun halt eng.
Vielleicht habe ich ihm
die Zeit dafür etwas genommen.
Weil er hier einen 100%-Job hat,
konnte er nicht in den Deutschkurs.
Er besuchte ihn
einen halben Tag pro Woche,
aber das ist einfach kein
Intensivkurs. Das ist zu wenig.
"Gülle und Mist
ist des Bauern List."
* Markus lacht. *
Bauer, List.
- List.
List bedeutet schlau.
List ist auch, ähm ...
Ja, ich weiss es nicht. Da müssen
wir im Buch schauen, was List ist.
Die Buchstaben? L?
L, I, S, T. List.
List, hm.
Ja, das ist ein Wort,
das du nicht kennst. Oder?
Diese Pflanzen sind zu bestimmen.
Sie gehören zur Prüfung.
Pro ... Schüler
sind acht Pflanzen zu bestimmen.
Einen Tag pro Woche besucht Tesfu
mit Bauernlehrlingen aus der Region
die Schule.
Die Prüfungen sind schwierig für ihn,
weil er oft gar nicht versteht,
was gefragt ist.
(Lehrer) Oft, mehr als einmal ...
Die Teilblätter
sind oft
etwas runder. Also, die ...
Junge, junge sind oft runder.
Das wäre ...
Ich muss sagen,
ich hatte mehr erwartet
beim ... Lernen, zu verstehen.
Die Hauptschwierigkeit
liegt bei der Sprache.
Er kann gut lesen,
aber das schriftliche
und mündliche Verständnis,
das sind die grössten Probleme.
Die individuelle Betreuung
kann ich in einer Klasse
mit zwölf Schülern nicht bieten.
Herr Adanon,
wir müssen jetzt hier abbrechen.
Dann gehen Sie an Ihren Platz
und Herr Giger setzt sich hier hin.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Auf dem Hof wächst und gedeiht es.
Nur der Plan mit Rava geht nicht auf.
Nachdem Markus mit ihr einen
Arbeitsvertrag abgeschlossen hatte,
erfuhr er, dass sie schwanger ist.
Das überraschte uns
natürlich schon ein bisschen.
Der Termin liegt im Oktober.
Das ist für uns
ein sehr ungünstiger Zeitpunkt.
Wir sagten,
das könnten wir nicht eingehen.
Und eigentlich ...
Alle anderen wussten Bescheid.
Wir fühlten uns dabei
etwas übergangen.
Mit dem Vater des Kindes
will Rava nichts zu tun haben.
Ramsers möchten helfen und sind
bereit, sie arbeiten zu lassen,
so lange sie kann.
Das muss jedoch
mit der Gemeinde abgesprochen sein,
denn Rava ist nach wie vor
nur vorläufig aufgenommen.
Sozialvorsteherin Charlotte
Hungerbühler kommt zum Gespräch.
* Unverständliche Unterhaltung *
Eine Variante wäre,
dass sie ganz hierherzieht.
Das wäre der eine Teil.
Das würde
einen Gemeindewechsel bedeuten.
Oder - wir müssen nochmals schauen,
wie Sie sich das vorstellen -,
Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie allenfalls etwas hätten,
an dem sie bereits jetzt
ein bisschen arbeiten kann,
und sie
in einem Heim wohnen würde.
Markus möchte,
dass Rava auf dem Hof wohnen
und nach der Geburt
weiterarbeiten kann.
Aber die Kosten für den
Mutterschaftsurlaub, findet er,
müsste schon
die Gemeinde übernehmen.
Wie würde es denn aussehen,
wenn sie hier wohnen würde?
Sie bekommt einen fixen Betrag,
resp. die Gemeinde
bekommt einen Pauschalbetrag,
mit dem wir
alles finanzieren müssen.
Wie hoch ist der?
D.h. ... Moment, bitte.
Sie bekommt ihr Taggeld ausbezahlt,
pro Woche.
Alles andere wird für Wohnung,
Miete, Krankenkasse,
Spezial... Also Zahlungen
für Schule etc. verwendet.
Das geht relativ schnell
ebenerdig auf.
Da haben wir keine grossen Reserven.
Daher müssen wir
seitens Gemeinde überlegen,
wie wir das gut handhaben können.
Denn sonst bezahlen wir drauf.
Wie hoch ist der Betrag?
- 41 Fr., Plusminus.
Pro Tag?
- Pro Tag.
Bezahlt das der Bund?
- Bund und Kanton, ja.
Der Bund bezahlt.
Ja, von dort geht es zum Kanton
und der verteilt es.
Ja.
Aber nicht die Gemeinde Müllheim?
Was darüber hinausgeht,
bezahlt natürlich die Gemeinde.
Da, denke ich,
sind es wieder Steuergelder,
die man auch anschauen muss.
Das ist so das.
Ja, das stimmt. Deshalb wollen wir
diese Leute ja auch beschäftigen.
Im Augenblick
bekommt Rava 77 Fr. pro Woche.
Hätte sie Arbeit, könnte sie Zimmer
und Krankenkasse selbst bezahlen.
Nur für den Mutterschaftsurlaub
müsste die Gemeinde aufkommen.
Die Sozialvorsteherin
verspricht zwar,
sich um die Angelegenheit zu kümmern.
Doch Markus ist ernüchtert,
dass sein Angebot
auf so wenig Begeisterung stösst.
Wenn sie es aus ihrem Sack
bezahlen müssten, es cash hinlegen,
würden sie anders reagieren.
Sie hat ja gesagt,
es sei kein Gewinn für sie.
Oder?
Das ist doch ein Gewinn.
Ja ...
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Die, ja, die haben einfach...
Der Lohn kommt für sie einfach.
Nicht nur die Gemeinde,
auch Markus muss rechnen.
Viele Bauern in der Schweiz
geben auf,
er arbeitet
immer noch 14 Std. pro Tag.
Und es wären noch mehr,
wenn er Tesfu nicht hätte.
Zudem arbeitet er gerne mit ihm.
* Friedliche Musik *
Er fährt super
mit diesen Maschinen.
Prioritäten setzen
kann er noch nicht so gut.
Wir sind natürlich schon
ein bisschen verrückt.
Was wir alles machen.
Wir machen viel zu viel.
Wir können nur von ihnen lernen -
oder sollten es tun.
Das Miteinander,
das sie pflegen,
und die Zufriedenheit.
Das wäre ja eigentlich
das Wichtigste.
Wir machen einfach,
was sein muss.
Und eben: zu viel.
In der Regel zu viel.
Aber wir stecken halt einfach ...
da drin.
Und wir leben damit.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Drei Wochen später.
Es ist Juni.
Von Rava weit und breit keine Spur.
Komm, hü! Hopp!
Es wäre geplant gewesen, dass Rava
das hätte erledigen können.
Damit ich während dieser Zeit
etwas entlastet würde.
Das wäre wichtig gewesen.
Von der Gemeinde
hat Markus Ramser nichts mehr gehört.
Es sieht nicht so aus,
als könnte sie überhaupt anfangen.
So wie es im Moment ...
Und die Zeit läuft ja ... gegen sie,
oder.
Ja, es ist ...
... nicht ganz das,
was wir uns gewünscht hätten.
Alle würden gewinnen. Alle.
Nur die Gemeinde Müllheim nicht.
Es geht um das Zimmer,
das sie in Müllheim hat.
Das dürfte sie
eigentlich nicht aufgeben.
Würde Rava dieses Zimmer aufgeben,
würde der Bund nichts mehr bezahlen,
und das wolle die Gemeinde
offenbar nicht.
Ramser hat einen Verdacht:
Es scheint, dass die Gemeinde ...
... an diesen Leuten Geld verdient.
Aber wenn die klemmen,
bezahlt halt jetzt der Bund -
und wir als Steuerzahler.
Da kann sie schon sagen ...
Sie sagte ja an der Sitzung:
"Das müsst ihr
dem Steuerzahler beibringen."
Aber das, was sie jetzt macht,
ist ja viel schlechter.
Wie befürchtet sieht die Gemeinde
keine Lösung für Markus' Anliegen.
Aus dem Plan für Rava wird nichts.
Sie muss in Müllheim bleiben.
Emmi macht derweil weiter
mit ihrem Integrationsprogramm
für Tesfus Frau Merhawit.
Das heisst ...?
* Merhawit spricht unverständlich. *
Löffel.
- Löffel.
Gabel.
Messer.
- Genau.
Weisst du, was das ist?
Eine Pfanne.
- Pfanne.
Pfanne, ja.
Peperoni rein
und auch ein bisschen dünsten.
Ja.
Alles rein.
Sie macht das gut.
V.a. ist sie sehr aufnahmefähig.
Siehst du?
Zwiebeln schneiden,
das geht bei ihr zack, zack.
Sie macht das besser als ich.
Und wenn sie etwas mal gemacht hat,
vergisst sie es nicht mehr.
Sie macht es danach
bereits selbstständig.
Ich bin wirklich erstaunt,
dass sie so aufnahmefähig ist.
Nicht alle
sind gleichermassen begeistert,
dass sich Markus und Emmi
für Eritreer engagieren.
Ihre beiden Söhne z.B.
finden es nicht so toll.
Unser Sohn ... hält sich da raus.
Er ist ...
... halt nicht
für so etwas zu haben.
Sie haben einfach das Gefühl, diese
Menschen gehören nicht hierher.
Die sollen bleiben,
wo sie herkommen.
Wir lassen ihnen ihre Meinung
und sie müssen uns ...
das einfach zugestehen.
Es ist unsere Sache und
geht sie eigentlich auch nichts an.
Klar ist es schade.
Man könnte es auch gemeinsam machen.
Aber nein, das geht nicht.
Markus ist noch eher etwas ...
Er kommt noch eher ...
Denn er ist ja ...
... schlussendlich auch immer froh,
solche Leute zu haben.
Markus junior ist auch der einzige,
der sich äussert.
Er betreibt gleich neben
dem elterlichen Hof eine Hühnerfarm.
So schlecht,
wie seine Mutter vermutet,
denkt er über das Integrationsprojekt
gar nicht.
Grundsätzlich
ist das eine gute Sache.
Wir können das auch unterstützen.
Von anderen ...
Es wird auch von
anderen Berufsverbänden unterstützt.
Grundsätzlich ist das gut.
Vielleicht muss man einfach
bei der Auswahl der Personen
sehr, sehr vorsichtig sein.
Es wird wahrscheinlich nicht
mit allen Nationalitäten gehen -
oder es braucht
einfach noch mehr Geduld.
Und diese Zeit
haben die meisten Betriebe nicht.
Er selbst arbeitet seit Jahren
mit polnischen Arbeitskräften.
Die Leute von dort
haben sich eigentlich bewährt.
Viele kommen auch
aus der Landwirtschaft.
Früher war es so, dass die Leute,
die wieder nach Hause gingen,
einen guten Kollegen oder
einfach jemand Gutes vermittelten.
Durch meinen Vater
sind jetzt diese ...
... Eritreer
auf meinen Betrieb gekommen.
Ich hatte zum ersten Mal
Kontakt mit ihnen.
Vorher waren sie nicht verfügbar,
auch nicht fürs Arbeiten.
Man konnte sie
nicht einfach holen
und fragen, ob sie
zum Arbeiten kommen wollen.
Selbst im Projekt mitmachen
würde er wohl eher nicht.
Vielleicht nur, wenn alle
Eritreer oder Afrikaner wären,
dann vielleicht schon.
Was ich bei meinen Polen merke:
Wenn Afrikaner hier arbeiten -
die schwarze Hautfarbe
ist sofort ...
... fast ein No-Go bei ihnen.
Das ist etwas schwierig.
Man muss ihnen jeweils sagen ...
Dieses Rassismusproblem.
Man muss immer aufpassen,
dass kein Konflikt entsteht.
Osteuropäer haben eine ganz andere
Einstellung bei der Asylpolitik.
Sie kennen
und wollen das nicht.
Diese Haltung spürt man.
Und die bringen sie auch hierher.
Markus
findet es mit den Polen einfacher.
Er ahnt aber schon, warum sein Vater
es jetzt mit Eritreern probiert.
Es war für ihn vielleicht auch
ein bisschen eine Herausforderung.
Bei ihm beginnt bald
ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
Vielleicht brauchte er
einfach noch mal etwas,
bei dem er sich austoben konnte.
Oder einfach
eine neue Herausforderung.
Es ist aber nicht nur die Heraus-
forderung, die Markus motiviert.
Er fühlt sich auch verpflichtet.
Ich finde,
die Bauern bekommen so viel
von der Volkswirtschaft,
dass sie auch etwas
dafür leisten dürfen.
Das ist ... vielleicht
für die einen etwas zynisch.
Die hören das nicht gerne.
Aber ich bin der Meinung,
dass es für die Integration
nichts Besseres gibt.
Zudem macht es mit Tesfu
auch mehr Spass.
Die Kartoffelfelder müssen von
Unkraut befreit werden, ohne Chemie.
Das braucht Manpower.
* Beschauliche Klänge *
Tja, es hat überall.
Da ist noch einer.
Hier ist wieder ...
Was ist das?
Amaranth.
- Melde.
Melde, ja, sorry.
- Ja.
Es wachsen immer wieder neue.
Alle haben wir nicht gefunden,
aber ...
... Beikräuter müssen sein.
Wir können es immer zu zweit machen.
Wir müssen einfach mehr machen.
Das ist so.
Wir hätten auch jetzt ...
Wenn ich auf mein normales
Arbeitspensum reduzieren würde,
bräuchte ich
einen zusätzlichen Mann.
* Beruhigende Klänge *
Markus
kann immer noch nicht reduzieren.
Im Gegenteil: Auch am Morgen
ist er der Erste im Stall.
Er hat halt Arbeitszeiten.
Er hätte zu viele Stunden, wenn
er so früh beginnen würde wie ich.
Abends wird es auch wieder 19 Uhr,
bis wir fertig sind.
Tagsüber kann ich ihm nicht frei-
geben. Das liegt bei uns nicht drin.
Deshalb muss ich halt
am Morgen dafür herhalten.
Das macht mir auch nichts aus.
Wir sind uns das gewöhnt.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Jeder macht sein Ding.
Markus und Tesfu
haben eine Beziehung aufgebaut,
die nicht vieler Worte bedarf.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Kannst du noch die Gurken bewässern?
Hast du?
- Gestern.
Jetzt auch schnell.
Wenn du schon mal hier bist.
Toll, wie das wächst.
Das macht er sehr gerne
nach dem Frühstück.
Er geht zu seinem Beet.
Es ist seins.
Dann
kümmert er sich um die Pflanzen,
spricht mit ihnen.
Sie wachsen auch ...
Die wachsen wie verrückt.
Aber hier
vergisst er sich öfters mal.
Hier ist er zu Hause.
Wenn du für dich welche brauchst,
musst du ...
Hast du noch? Da kannst du
schon geben. Das ist in Ordnung.
Die Idylle scheint perfekt,
doch bei Tesfu zu Hause
bahnen sich Veränderungen an.
Rava ist zu Besuch.
Sie ist im fünften Monat schwanger.
Und sie ist offenbar
nicht die Einzige:
Zur grossen Überraschung aller
erwartet auch Merhawit ein Kind.
Auch sie ist im fünften Monat,
hat es aber lange verheimlicht.
Konkrete Vorstellungen, wie das Leben
mit einem Kind wird, hat sie nicht.
Auch Tesfu scheint es zu nehmen,
wie es kommt.
Merhawit muss kurz nach ihrer Ankunft
schwanger geworden sein.
Markus und Emmi lassen sich
ihre Überraschung nicht anmerken.
Musst du den Garten zeigen?
Ja. Rava,
willst du den Garten sehen?
Sie kommt mit der Schwangerschaft
besser klar als Tesfu.
Für ihn ist das erst mal
eine Überraschung.
Aber ...
... er wird sich damit abfinden.
Man muss das Beste draus machen
und ihr helfen,
damit sie nicht einfach so ...
dahin ...
Ja, man muss halt raus
und etwas unternehmen.
Wenn man das Gefühl hat, eine
Schwangerschaft sei eine Krankheit,
ist das halt
nicht wirklich das Wahre.
Ernüchterung macht sich breit.
Emmi hat wenig Verständnis
für Merhawits Passivität.
Jetzt muss ich sagen,
als sie einfach meinte,
sie wolle
nichts mehr im Garten machen,
sie wolle nicht raus und so.
Und dann sage ich einfach:
"Irgendwann sage ich vielleicht
einfach auch nur noch Nein."
Sie können zu mir kommen und sagen:
"Mami, fährst du mich zum Bahnhof?"
"Mami, ich möchte einkaufen."
Das machst du alles.
Wie wäre es, wenn ich
auch einfach mal Nein sagen würde?
Weiss denn Tesfu wenigstens,
wie es Merhawit geht
und was sie beschäftigt?
Sie sagt nicht,
dass es nicht gut geht.
Das sagt sie nicht, aber ...
Aber sie, ja ...
"So la la", hat sie gesagt.
Offensichtlich ist jedoch,
dass sie Gartenarbeit nicht mag.
* Sie spricht tigrinisch. *
Oh mein Gott.
* Er spricht tigrinisch. *
"Was würde sie denn lieber tun?",
fragt sie Tesfu.
* Sie spricht tigrinisch. *
Sie ...
Es ist Sommer.
Markus und Tesfu jäten in den Randen.
Für ein Schwätzchen reicht's immer.
* Beide lachen. *
Hast du gesehen? Das ist Krautfäule.
- Nicht gut, oder?
Ist schon gut, macht nichts.
Jetzt muss es weg.
Jetzt ist es an der Zeit.
Wann beginnt die Ernte?
Nächste Woche?
Hm, vielleicht.
Immer noch sind sie zu zweit,
doch das wird nicht mehr reichen,
wenn die Ernte beginnt.
Ja, ja, jetzt brauche ich die Leute.
Jetzt brauche ich die Leute.
Wir müssen noch die
von Markus' Betrieb holen.
Und er hat wieder
einen Eritreer gefunden.
Wieder einen
aus dem Asylheim in Müllheim.
Mit der Sozialvorsteherin dort
wolle er aber
lieber nichts mehr zu tun haben.
Ich habe gesagt, ich schaue
mit dem Kanton, nicht mehr mit ihr.
Da diskutiere ich nicht.
Sonst beginnen wir wieder am 1. Mai.
Und sind in drei Monaten ...
Dann ist Winter.
Dann brauche ich
auch niemanden mehr.
Seit der Sache mit Rava
ist das Verhältnis
zur Gemeinde Müllheim getrübt.
Markus hat einen Termin
beim Gemeindepräsidenten.
Ein Gespräch soll Klarheit schaffen.
Der Gemeindepräsident ...
... ist natürlich jemand,
die mir ...
... ziemlich überlegen ist -
von ...
Einfach von der Bildung her.
Er wird sich sicher rechtfertigen.
Der Gemeindepräsident
will mit Markus alleine reden
und keine Stellung nehmen.
1 Std. dauert das Gespräch.
Wir haben einander
nicht den Kopf abgerissen.
Es war eigentlich
ein gutes Gespräch.
Aber es funktioniert nur schriftlich
mit der Gemeinde Müllheim.
Wir müssen das schriftlich
festhalten, einen Antrag stellen.
Wie es so laufen muss.
Mündlich ... ist es schwierig.
So unbürokratisch,
wie Markus sich das vorgestellt hat,
geht es mit dieser Gemeinde
definitiv nicht.
Markus kämpft an vielen Fronten.
Auch Merhawits Passivität
will er nicht einfach hinnehmen.
Er hat sie überredet,
ihm die Haare zu schneiden.
Das muss ich meiner Coiffeuse -
ich gehe auch immer zu einer Frau
zum Haare schneiden -
zeigen und sagen, ich hätte
eine andere Coiffeuse gefunden.
Papa.
Zeigen!
Oh mein Gott.
Zu viel weg.
Gut?
- Ja.
He?
Nimmt zu viel weg.
Es ist ihm zu kurz.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Während Markus versucht und versucht,
gibt Emmi langsam auf.
Auf Merhawit zählt sie nicht mehr.
Nach einem halben Jahr hat sie ihr
Integrationsprogramm auf Eis gelegt.
Für mich ist es eine Enttäuschung,
dass sie nicht von sich aus etwas
mehr Motivation und Interesse zeigt.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich könnte
mit ihr machen, was ich will,
das Interesse ist einfach nicht da.
Deshalb habe ich mir vorgenommen,
sie einfach in Ruhe zu lassen,
mich nicht mehr
wirklich um sie zu bemühen.
Denn es bringt einfach nichts.
Auf die Erntezeit hin
darf Markus nun
den Eritreer aus dem Asylheim
in Müllheim zu 60 % anstellen.
Der Kanton hat grünes Licht gegeben.
Robi hatte ich sowieso im Visier,
um ihn in den Betrieb zu nehmen,
nebst Rava.
Aber er hatte
die B-Bewilligung noch nicht.
Nun sagten sie, er könne
mit der N-Bewilligung arbeiten.
Jetzt habe ich ihn angestellt.
Markus hält schon fast störrisch
an seinem Integrationsplan
für die Eritreer fest,
auch wenn ihm die neue Anstellung
wieder gehörig Papierkram beschert.
Ich muss einen Vertrag machen,
und diese ...
... diese Ausländerbewilligung
einholen.
Wie heisst das?
Vielleicht habe ich noch einen.
Dann auch
mit den Versicherungen schauen.
Das muss halt alles klappen.
Erneut hat er den Eindruck,
dass die Gemeinde Müllheim
sein Engagement für die Flüchtlinge
nicht unterstützt.
Es sind immer die von den Gemeinden,
die dagegen sind,
dass sie arbeiten
und bei Privaten wohnen dürfen.
Sie haben immer das Gefühl,
sie machen zu viel.
Sie wollen,
dass sie irgendwann die Nase voll
haben und freiwillig wieder gehen.
Das wollen sie.
Dass sie einen Rückzug machen.
Aber von denen, die hier sind,
macht keiner
freiwillig einen Rückzug.
Da geht keiner
in dieses Land zurück.
Sie wissen, wie hundsmiserabel
es ihnen dort gehen würde.
Es ist Herbst geworden.
Vor zwei Wochen hat Robi angefangen.
Robi, hier, komm.
Hast du noch welche?
Der 35-Jährige
ist seit 2015 in der Schweiz,
ist aber
nicht mal vorläufig aufgenommen.
Müssen wir es nochmals ausleeren?
Er hat den schlechtesten Status N
und wartet auf seinen Asylentscheid.
Den Rest ...
... finden die Tiere schon.
Einfach hier rein.
Magst du Schnaps?
- Ja.
Ja? Schon? Aber nicht zu viel.
- Nicht viel.
Sonst da ...
Kopfschmerzen.
Ja, viel trinken
gibt Kopfschmerzen.
Viel.
- Viel trinken gibt Kopfschmerzen.
Ja, ja, irgendwann.
Steigen wir ... auf den Traktor.
Willst du fahren?
Wieder geht das Integrationsprogramm
von vorne los.
Rum, rum, rum.
Schön rechts fahren, in Ordnung?
Nicht in der Mitte.
Markus ist froh,
hat er seine Leute zusammen.
Gell, Susanne.
- Mhm.
Morgen früh müssen wir schauen ...
Heute Morgen dachten wir ...
Wir haben doch ein Auto dort?
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Schau her!
Jetzt hat sie aber gut getippt.
Bei der Kartoffelernte
braucht es jede Hand.
Noch etwas Gas geben.
Gib nicht zu viel Gas.
Emmi ist begeistert von Robi.
Der macht das super.
Der ist so flink.
Da komme ich nicht mit.
Er ist extrem flink, doch.
Er macht das sehr ...
Er ist ein ganz Süsser.
Er sieht immer, macht immer. Ja.
Aber auch mit ihm
gibt es schon wieder Probleme:
Als er kam, brachte er direkt
den Entscheid aus Bern mit.
Der ist negativ.
Das HEKS
hat sich dann für ihn eingesetzt.
Sie schauen jetzt weiter,
dass er Rekurs einlegen kann.
Er hat bis am 20. ...
... 20. Oktober?
- Oktober, ja.
Ich denke,
mit Rekurs geht es länger.
Ich behalte ihn mal,
so lange es geht.
Wir hoffen für ihn,
dass ...
... der Rekurs etwas bringt.
Für ihn wäre es schön,
wenn er bleiben könnte.
Ich sage immer,
es habe genügend andere,
die man eigentlich
rausschicken könnte, die ...
Aber so einen wie ihn ...
kann man in der Schweiz brauchen.
Auf jeden Fall.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Während der Ernte hilft immer auch
Tesfus Schwester Oqua mit ihrem Mann
und ihren Kindern mit.
Sie sind gerne hier,
denn was auf dem Feld liegenbleibt,
dürfen sie behalten.
Alle übernachten bei Tesfu.
Merhawit ist mittlerweile
im achten Monat schwanger
und hält sich
v.a. in der Wohnung auf.
Hast du bereits Deutsch gelernt?
Deutsch sprechen?
Nein.
* Sie sprechen tigrinisch. *
Ist gut.
Tesfu muss noch lernen.
Ich muss noch etwas schreiben.
Z.B. wenn wir
jetzt im Garten ernten,
muss ... ich das aufschreiben.
Dann ...
... muss ich es ausdrucken
und in die Schule bringen.
Kommst du gut mit in der Schule?
Verstehst du es gut?
Hochdeutsch ist besser. Aber jetzt
ist Schweizerdeutsch kein Problem.
* Geschirrklappern *
Ende Herbst.
Die Weide muss umgezäunt werden.
Warte kurz, warte.
Nein, nein, lassen.
So, jetzt.
Jetzt kannst du sie halten.
Ja, genau so. Diese halten.
Oder vielleicht ...
Der 20. Oktober ist bereits vorbei,
und Robi ist immer noch hier.
Seine Beschwerde ...
wurde gutgeheissen.
Jetzt geht es an die Vorinstanz,
ans SEM, zurück.
Das muss seine Situation
nochmals ...
... beurteilen.
Für mich
ist diese Arbeit einfach ...
... so ...
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Gut, Baba.
Robi gefällt's.
Tesfu hingegen fehlt.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Er ist anderweitig beschäftigt:
Seine Tochter Salem
ist zur Welt gekommen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Schon vor zwei Wochen. Eine Woche
war sie im Spital Frauenfeld.
Du musst lachen. Hoi.
Grosse Freude?
Glücklich?
* Tesfu übersetzt. *
Ja.
Bis hinauf ins Haupthaus zu Emmi
hat's Merhawit
allerdings noch nicht geschafft.
Diese ist einmal mehr enttäuscht
und ein bisschen ratlos.
Das mit dem aus-dem-Haus-gehen.
Man bringt sie wirklich nicht raus.
Ich habe ihre Schwester gebeten,
ihr zu sagen, das sei wichtig.
Jetzt war
wirklich auch schönes Wetter.
Und sie ...
Sie geht nicht raus.
Auch die Rollläden sind nie oben.
In Eritrea ist es so:
Am zwölften Tag gehen sie
mit den Neugeborenen mal raus,
quasi,
um einen Vitaminschub zu holen.
Danach gehen sie nicht mehr raus,
bis das Kind 30 Tage alt ist.
V.a. bei den Frauen
ist die Integration schwierig.
Sie wollen es einfach so haben,
wie es bei ihnen war.
Und das finde ich halt schade.
So, ihr könnt noch etwas warten.
Ihr wisst, was los ist.
Es gibt neues Futter.
Auch Markus ist nicht zufrieden.
Durch die neue Situation
wird der Kulturunterschied
auch bei Tesfu
mit einem Mal ziemlich deutlich.
Die Arbeitsleistung
hat etwas gelitten.
Er muss sich jetzt ziemlich intensiv
mit seiner Familie beschäftigen.
Durch die Geburt ist jetzt
noch ein Mitglied dazugekommen.
Wir sind
mitten in den Herbstarbeiten.
Für mich ist das natürlich ...
nicht unbedingt optimal.
Nicht so optimal ist auch Tesfus
Tempo, was die Lehre angeht.
Der neue Weizen muss ausgesät werden.
Noch ein Drittel dazu.
Ein Drittel. Gut.
Das ist jetzt die Hälfte.
Bis zu seinem Lehrabschluss bleibt
nur noch ein knappes halbes Jahr.
1,3.
1,3? Aufmachen und noch mal.
- Puh.
Ja, "puh".
1,7?
Ja, ja. Ja, du musst entscheiden.
Das muss er eben können.
Das muss er eben können,
wenn er die Prüfung macht.
Dann muss er das beherrschen.
Wenn Tesfu seine Prioritäten
nicht bald anders setzt,
drohen er und damit auch Markus'
ehrgeiziges Projekt zu scheitern.
Viel Plastik an der Maschine.
1,9.
Jetzt passt's.
Jetzt bin ich zufrieden.
Du auch?
Bist du jetzt auch zufrieden?
Mhm.
Muss, oder?
1,8 ist besser, oder?
Nein, 1,9 passt. 1,8-1,9.
Das ist gut.
Der erste Schnee.
Da bleibt auch mal Zeit
für ein bisschen Schweizer Tradition.
Dann so abziehen.
Nachher einpacken.
* Sie sprechen tigrinisch. *
Jawohl.
Wenn du in die Migros gehst,
kauf 250 g. In Ordnung?
Bisschen gut.
Aber ich bin nicht Käsermeister,
weisst du.
Ich bin Bauer.
Nach einem Dreivierteljahr ist klar:
Vieles ist anders herausgekommen, als
Markus sich das vorgestellt hatte.
Super wäre natürlich,
wenn jetzt Rava hier wäre.
Ich gönne es Robi auch,
dass er eine Stelle hat
und sich einarbeiten kann.
Aber mit Rava und ihr gemeinsam
würde es auf dem Hof
besser funktionieren.
Denn sie könnten
einander ergänzen bei der ...
Kinderbetreuung.
Dann hätte ich Tesfu
auch etwas mehr auf dem Betrieb.
Und trotzdem: Markus ist überzeugt,
dass ein Kulturaustausch wie dieser
nicht nur den Flüchtlingen, sondern
auch den Bauern etwas bringen würde.
In jedem Betrieb einer,
um den man sich kümmert.
Dann kämen wir
der Sache schon etwas näher.
Das wäre so das, was ich
als meine Vision empfehlen könnte.
Einfach alles etwas ruhiger nehmen.
Ah! Gut.
Das ist gut.
Das ist perfekt, die Form.
Der hier ist besonders schön.
Der ist ganz schön.
Den geben wir Mama.
Qualität, jawohl.
Es ist kurz vor Weihnachten.
Tesfu, bringst du mir
einen roten Schneemann?
Nein, Tesfu, komm. Bring einen
roten Schneemann mit Mütze raus.
Robi, bring einen grünen Schneemann.
So. Jetzt.
Ihr könnt auf der Hinterseite
diese beiden hinstellen.
Die beiden, die noch hier sind,
kommen auf die Vorderseite.
Du musst ...
- Mit singen oder was?
Ja, genau.
Du kannst singen, oder?
Gut? Kapiert?
- Okay.
* Sie pfeifen und trällern
"We Wish You a Merry Christmas". *
Wohin stellen?
Genau.
Kannst du es drehen?
Ja. So.
Super.
- Du kannst zumachen.
# La, la, la.
Nimmst du das Rotkraut?
Das magst du nicht. Tesfu,
Ich habe für dich Bohnen gemacht.
Mhm.
Nimm das mit. Achtung, heiss.
Ja, ist gut.
Jawohl.
So, das ist euer Fleisch.
Das auch.
Emmi hat Salem gehütet.
Merhawit war im Deutschkurs.
Hoppla.
Sie schläft jetzt. Lass sie.
Kommt, esst jetzt.
- Ja. Komm, essen.
Siehst du? Salem gefällt es hier.
(Merhawit) Mama, Salem ...
- Nur einmal.
Schlafen?
- Nein, sie war schon wach.
Einmal um 10 Uhr,
da hat sie ein bisschen gejammert.
Dann habe ich ihr Tee gegeben.
Hast du noch Salat?
Hat sie Tee getrunken?
- Ja, sicher.
Schon?
Ja. Ihr müsst das
mal ein bisschen probieren mit Tee.
Ja, Flüssigkeit.
- In der Mütterberatung ...
Also,
jetzt gebe ich gerne zu trinken.
Essen, da musst du warten ...
fünf bis sechs Monate.
Nein, nur drei Monate.
Mit drei Monaten kannst ...
Jetzt ist es besser
nur mit Muttermilch.
Ja, ja, bei euch schon.
Wenn sie genug Milch hat,
ist es gut.
Aber sie muss auch lernen, zu essen.
Z.B. Bananen mit Äpfeln.
Und ...
Jetzt?
- Mit drei Monaten.
Auf tigrinisch?
- Auf tigrinisch ist es ...
Kann man das nicht sagen?
Ich weiss es nicht. Misah.
"Müsa"?
- Ja.
* Er spricht tigrinisch. *
Wie? "Tomesä".
Was heisst das?
Guten Appetit.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Langsam, so scheint es,
ist Merhawit doch in der Schweiz
und bei Ramsers angekommen.
Sie ist etwas älter geworden.
Sie ist jetzt Mutter.
Sie trägt jetzt Verantwortung.
Und sie hat Freude an ihrem Kind.
Sie sagt auch immer schön freundlich
Grüezi mit der Hand. Es läuft gut.
Einfach das Deutsch
bereitet ihr Mühe.
Da kommt sie
nicht wirklich vom Fleck.
Tesfu sollte ein bisschen
mehr deutsch sprechen mit ihr.
Wenn sie den ganzen Tag alleine ist,
spricht niemand mit ihr.
Dieses St. Gallen
kann er nicht sein lassen.
Er fährt
jedes Wochenende hin.
Am Freitagabend oder am Samstag geht
er und kommt erst am Sonntag zurück.
Ich hätte erwartet, dass er jetzt
eher mal zu Hause bleiben würde,
aber dieses St. Gallen und
diese Kirche gehören einfach zu ihm.
Praktisch jedes Wochenende ist Tesfu
mit den Leuten von der Kirchgemeinde
unterwegs. Kein Wunder, interessiert
er sich für Emmis grosse Krippe.
Kein Problem. Mach nur.
Es geht schon.
Es hat mir Spass gemacht,
Figuren zu basteln.
Am Anfang war die Krippe ganz klein,
dann wurde sie immer grösser.
So gross ist sie
sicher seit bald zehn Jahren.
Ich stelle sie
jedes Jahr wieder auf.
Das ist unsere Weihnacht,
das gehört dazu.
Welcher König ist das?
Ich weiss nicht, welcher wie heisst.
Die musst du
zu denen dort hinstellen.
Ist das eine Ziege?
- Ja. Nein, das sind kleine Schafe.
Die Schafe sind dort.
Stell sie zu den Schafen.
Nein, stell sie zu den Schafen.
Das sind alles Ziegen.
- Das ist auch noch eine Ziege.
Nicht ganz so. Aber ...
Zu Hause
ist ein kleiner Baum mit Lichtern.
Genau.
(Tesfu) Zu den Tieren, oder?
* Sanfte, gläserne Klänge *
Kurz vor Neujahr.
Grosse Aufregung zu Hause bei Tesfu:
Töchterchen Salem wird getauft.
In Eritrea ist das ein grosses Fest.
Aus der ganzen Schweiz sind
eritreische Landsleute angereist.
Bist du nervös?
- Ein bisschen schon.
* Tesfu spricht tigrinisch. *
Alle sind nervös.
Der hat sich da etwas aufgehalst.
* (Dumpf) Der Pfarrer
spricht tigrinisch. *
Auch der eritreische Pfarrer
aus St. Gallen
ist extra für die Zeremonie
nach Müllheim gekommen.
* Der Pfarrer spricht tigrinisch. *
* Fröhliche Musik *
* Feierlicher Gesang *
Für Markus ist diese Taufe einer
der wenigen Einblicke in Tesfus Welt.
* Stimmengewirr *
Es dauerte ziemlich lange.
Und das Kind ...
Bei uns geht das
immer so schnell vorbei.
Das war sehr eindrücklich.
Das hat mich berührt, ja.
Eindrücklich, ja,
wie sie miteinander gehen.
Aber es
ist nicht alles Verwandtschaft.
Es sind Verwandte dabei,
wie ich gehört habe.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
wie sie sich organisieren.
Autos mit Kennzeichen aus der ganzen
Schweiz stehen auf dem Parkplatz.
Das Fest
haben v.a. Oqua und Emmi vorbereitet.
Bist du fertig mit Kochen?
- Ja.
Ja? Ich habe Hunger.
Mh? Ich? Ja, ja.
- Nein, ich!
Dankbar ist v.a. seine Schwester.
Es war ganz lieb:
Gestern kam sie zu mir -
und das machte mich ziemlich stolz -
und sagte: "Papa und du, ihr seid
der Papa und die Mama von Tesfu."
Ja, sie schätzt das.
Auch jetzt wieder.
Sie hat sich bedankt. Sie ist eine
ganz Liebe. Und sie schätzt es sehr.
Für Merhawit
ist es selbstverständlich.
Von ihr kann ich wohl
keinen Dank erwarten.
Aber das ist Schaf?
Nein, nicht scharf.
- Nicht scharf? Dann ist gut.
Aber das ist auch Schaf?
Nein, das nicht. Das und das dort
sind etwas schärfer.
Aber Sie können probieren.
Nein, Schaf, nicht scharf.
- Ach so.
Ein bisschen hiervon. Oh, pass auf.
Ein bisschen, so. Sosse.
* Entspannte, rhythmische Musik *
Kaum ist die Taufe vorbei,
taucht wieder ein neues Problem auf.
Merhawit muss Ausreisepapiere
aus Eritrea einreichen.
Solche hat sie aber nicht.
Ramsers kommen aus dem Papierkrieg
nicht heraus.
Es ist ein Mist. - Es fehlt bei ihr
auch immer am Willen.
Man macht es, aber es braucht Zeit.
- Ja, das braucht es wirklich.
Es ist immer wieder ärgerlich.
- Ja.
Es ist ...
Es summiert sich.
Diese Behörden
werden schliesslich dafür bezahlt.
Und wir machen das einfach so.
Es ist unsere Zeit,
die wir hergeben,
um ihnen zu helfen.
Entsprechend ärgert es einen,
wenn die Büros einfach sagen können:
"Dieses und jenes wollen wir."
Obwohl sie eigentlich wissen,
dass es unmöglich ist.
Auch mit der Ausbildung von Tesfu
hat Markus alle Hände voll zu tun.
Die praktische Abschlussprüfung
ist in gut drei Monaten.
Wenn sich Tesfu nicht anstrengt,
reicht's wohl nicht.
Doch, doch.
22.
Nein, weisst du, diese hier.
Der ist immer noch nicht weg.
Zuerst diese, oder?
Aufpassen mit den Ringen.
Ja,
das muss er an der Prüfung können.
Das sind die einfachsten.
Er macht grosse Fortschritte.
Ich bin zuversichtlich.
Wo es vielleicht nicht klappen wird,
ist in der Schule,
im fachlichen Teil.
Es kann sein, dass er dort
etwas Mühe bekunden wird.
Aber beim praktischen Teil
mache ich mir keine Sorgen.
Hier sind die Stunden angegeben.
Nach wie vielen Stunden
musst du das machen?
Das 21.
Bei wie vielen Stunden?
200.
- Alle 200 Std.
Wenn du 200 Std. gefahren bist,
musst du den Ölwechsel machen
und den Filter wechseln.
Mit dem Deutsch hapert es immer noch.
Er müsste
in der Freizeit mehr machen.
Aber die Freizeit
ist bei ihm halt ausgebucht.
Dort müsste er etwas mehr machen,
ganz eindeutig.
Weil es wirklich knapp werden könnte,
hat die Schule einen Nachhilfelehrer
zur Verfügung gestellt.
Tesfu hat v.a. Probleme,
sich verständlich auszudrücken.
Wenn der Lehrer etwas sagt,
ist das kein Problem.
Ich verstehe alles.
Aber ... wenn ich ...
dem Lehrer etwas erklären muss,
das ist das Problem.
Er muss einen Vortrag vorbreiten.
Ich möchte v.a.,
dass du den Vortrag hältst. - Ja.
Und kannst du das auch mir erzählen,
wie du es Herrn Rohner erzählst?
Ja?
- Ja.
Der Betrieb wird seit 21 Jahren
organisch-biologisch bewirtschaftet.
Die Ausstallung ...
Laufstall, Milchstand ...
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Boxen.
Alles verstanden?
Ja, ja. Hast du es auch verstanden?
- Ja.
Du wirst am Montag den Vortrag so
halten. Du hast ein Notizblatt ...
Ein bisschen
muss ich das auch so üben.
Aber man kann nicht immer
so ablesen.
Auch ein bisschen so.
- Aber du machst das gut.
Doch, du schaust aufs Blatt ...
- Ach, gut.
Du schaust auf das Blatt,
dann wieder zu mir.
Ich habe auch mit dem Klassenlehrer,
mit Herrn Rohner, gesprochen.
Ich glaube, er liegt schon unter dem
erforderlichen Schnitt, der Note 4.
Genau.
Emmi
hat erneut einen Anlauf genommen,
Merhawit ein bisschen
Schweizer Kultur zu vermitteln.
Merhawit, was denkst du,
wie viele Kartoffeln wir brauchen?
Eine, zwei, drei?
- Drei.
Drei? Zwei?
* Sanfte Klänge *
Aber wann gibst du Salem Karotten?
Am Morgen?
Nein, nein, am Nachmittag.
Am Nachmittag? Das ist gut. Ja.
Nachher, in zwei Wochen oder so,
darfst du zusätzlich Äpfel
und Bananen geben.
Dann kannst du um 12 oder 13 Uhr
Gemüse füttern
und um 16 oder 17 Uhr
kannst du Banane und Äpfel füttern.
Sechs Monate, fünf Monate.
Nein, du kannst schon jetzt,
in zwei Wochen. - Ah, zwei Wochen.
Mir geht es v.a. auch um die Kleine,
dass sie ...
dass sie auf gut Deutsch gesagt
schweizerisch aufwächst.
Nicht da ...
Die würden
jetzt einfach stillen und stillen.
Sie ist fiel fast aus allen Wolken,
als ich gesagt habe, mit drei Mo-
naten könne sie feste Nahrung geben.
Bei uns ist es
halt ein bisschen anders.
Ich finde es wichtig für sie,
dass sie das so lernt.
Warte kurz.
So.
Schau mal.
Nicht heiss.
Mmh, mmh, das schmeckt aber gut.
Da muss man vorne schneiden.
Hm?
Ich mache es so.
Voll schneiden.
Und hier stecken.
Es ist März.
Tesfu ist durch ein Integrations-
projekt des Bauernverbandes
auf den Hof von Markus gekommen.
Nun will Vizedirektor Urs Schneider
sehen, wie es läuft.
Damit es eine schöne Krone gibt?
- Ja.
Nur den Hauptast anschneiden,
in Ordnung?
Er hat jetzt ein kleines Problem.
Wenn er diese schönen ...
Um die tut es dir leid, oder?
Wenn er die sieht, dann sagt er:
"Uh!"
Man muss es
ihnen einfach gut zeigen.
Jawohl.
Schnell etwas Theorie machen
und dann einfach mit ihnen arbeiten.
Dann läuft das.
Ja. Aber es ist wichtig,
auch die richtige Person zu haben,
die auch bereit ist,
etwas zu lernen und zu arbeiten.
Das spielt sicher auch
eine grosse Rolle, oder?
Sicher, aber man muss ihnen
einfach die Freude weitergeben.
Also, die Möglichkeit
muss man ihnen geben.
Gut, du bist
natürlich auch ein Spezialfall.
Nein.
Wenn du das nicht
mit dieser Leidenschaft,
und auch mit Überzeugung
und Menschlichkeit machst,
funktioniert es nicht gleich.
Und das ist evtl. schon manchmal
ein Handicap bei uns.
Jetzt gehen wir rein.
Wegräumen?
- Nein. Wir machen später weiter.
Von den 30 Personen
in unserem Pilotprojekt
haben sieben abgebrochen,
da die gegenseitigen Erwartungen
nicht erfüllt werden konnten.
Eine unserer Erkenntnisse ist, dass
es wohl nie eine Masse geben wird,
die das machen kann.
Man hat gedacht,
dass das ausgeweitet wird
und ein Teil der Arbeitskräfte,
die bisher aus dem Osten kamen,
ersetzt werden könnte.
Das wird nicht der Fall sein.
Unsere Hoffnung resp. Erwartung ist,
dass dieses Pilotprojekt, das auf
nationaler Ebene abgewickelt wurde,
auf der kantonalen Ebene
eine Fortsetzung findet.
Dann sind natürlich die Gemeinden
und Migrationsämter gefordert,
wirklich sehr aktiv
gute ... Verhältnisse zu schaffen.
Ich würde es
den Gemeinden auferlegen,
dass sie ... ... für sie auch selber
ein bisschen suchen und schauen.
Arbeit gibt es
in jeder Gemeinde genug.
Tesfu, alles Gute, nochmals.
- Danke.
Danke vielmals, eine gute Zeit.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Machst du die Osterdekoration?
- Ja, aber ich hab keine Vögel mehr.
Die sind weg.
- Davongeflogen?
Je mehr Emmi wieder mit Merhawit zu
tun hat, desto mehr realisiert sie,
was die junge Frau stört.
Am Dienstagmorgen
habe ich Merhawit geholt,
um sie auf den Zug zu bringen.
Dann kommt Tesfu daher und
ich frage ihn: "Tesfu, wo warst du?"
"In Schaffhausen".
Er sei gerade zurückgekommen.
Merhawit wusste nicht, dass er
nicht nach Hause kommt am Abend.
Solche Sachen
muss er ihr halt sagen.
Da wurde sie schon ...
ein bisschen wütend.
Dann mussten wir halt sagen:
"Das geht nicht."
"Ihr müsst miteinander sprechen.
Ihr müsst Dinge besprechen."
Für ihn ist es selbstverständlich.
Es ist jahrelang so gelaufen.
Aber jetzt ist die Familie da.
Die geht jetzt vor.
Emmi und Markus
versuchen zu vermitteln,
doch bei Tesfu und Merhawit
hängt der Haussegen ziemlich schief.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Es gibt wieder mehr zu tun
auf dem Hof.
Die Randen müssen gesäubert werden.
Merhawits Problem mit den Ausreise-
papieren ist immer noch nicht gelöst.
Tesfu hat eine neue Aufforderung
bekommen, die Papiere einzureichen.
Aha. Das ist das Papier.
Das ist ...
- Ich kann das nicht machen.
Das ist ... Du musst etwas machen.
Du musst etwas machen.
Sonst muss deine Frau
plötzlich nach Eritrea zurück.
Kein Problem.
- Aber das ist nicht gut.
Dann muss Salem auch gehen.
Das ist nicht so einfach, weisst du.
Du musst auf die Botschaft.
Das geht nicht anders.
Und Merhawit muss auch mit.
Okay, ich probiere es mal.
- Ja, du musst.
Merhawit kann auf die Botschaft
gehen, aber ich gehe nicht.
Ja, sie muss gehen.
Kein Problem mehr.
- Mhm.
He?
Markus
kann ausnahmsweise nicht helfen.
Diese Angelegenheit
müsste Tesfu regeln.
Aber der Zeitpunkt
ist denkbar ungünstig.
Die Prüfungen stehen an und
die Ehekrise mit Merhawit eskaliert.
Am Tag vor Tesfus Abschlussprüfung
verschwindet Merhawit spurlos.
Es war alles etwas stressig,
also Prüfungsstress.
Er hatte vielleicht wenig
oder etwas weniger Zeit für sie.
Und ...
.. am Abend war ...
... Merhawit einfach nicht mehr da.
Er sagte, sie sei
mit dem Kinderwagen spazieren.
Um 19 Uhr, 19.30 Uhr
war sie immer noch nicht zurück.
Da wurde ihm etwas mulmig zumute.
Ich sagte: "Sie kann
ja nur bei der Schwester sein."
Merhawits Schwester lebt in Zug.
Mit viel Überredungskunst
gelingt es Markus, sie zurückzuholen.
Doch was die Gründe für ihr Ver-
schwinden waren, weiss Markus nicht.
Er spricht nicht gerne darüber.
Er versucht sofort auszuweichen.
Merhawit ist zwar wieder da.
Und scheint doch abwesend.
Ihr Mann Tesfu ist überfordert.
Gefangen zwischen den Ansprüchen
der neuen Heimat
und den Gepflogenheiten Eritreas.
Ich finde, es ist keine Liebe da.
Das fehlt ein bisschen.
Aber ich weiss auch nicht,
wie sie lieben, in ihrem Land.
Wie dort die Zustände sind.
Aus unserer Sicht ...
... fehlt ganz klar etwas.
Man fragt sich, warum Tesfu Merhawit
überhaupt in die Schweiz geholt hat.
Danke.
So.
Wieder versucht Markus,
zu vermitteln.
Müde?
Ja, schlafen. Gut.
Schlafen? Ja.
Geht es dir gut? Dir? Dir?
- Ja.
Gut?
Um Merhawit bei Laune zu halten,
hat er ihr sogar
einen Hofladen eingerichtet.
Hast du Geschirr?
Ich muss noch Körbchen holen.
Das wäre besser.
Die anderen sind schöner.
Aber die Eheleute gehen sich
aus dem Weg, wann immer es geht.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ein paar Wochen später.
Auf diesen Tag hat Markus lange
und unermüdlich hingearbeitet.
So, holen wir die mal raus.
Trotz aller privater Turbulenzen hat
Tesfu die Abschlussprüfung geschafft.
Wo ist Mama?
- In der Garage.
Natürlich wollte ich
dieses Ziel mit ihm erreichen.
Er hat sich auch dafür bedankt,
dass ich ihm so viel geholfen habe.
Das hat mich gefreut.
Es kommt etwas zurück.
Evtl. auch auf einem anderen Weg.
Es muss nicht direkt von ihm sein.
Irgendetwas kommt einfach zurück.
Weiss nicht.
Das ist ein grosser Tag für dich.
- Oh, ja. Ja.
Wir sitzen dort, oder?
Und was machen wir dann?
Warten.
- Warten?
Bis es heisst: Tesfu Adanom.
- Ah, okay.
Dann musst du nach vorne gehen.
- Ja.
Der Anlass ist festlich
und traditionell schweizerisch.
* Stimmengewirr *
80 Bauernlehrlinge schliessen
dieses Jahr in der Ostschweiz
die dreijährige Lehre ab.
Drei haben mit Tesfu zusammen
die zweijährige Attestlehre gemacht.
Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Tesfu geniesst es,
Teil davon zu sein.
* Applaus *
* Jodellied
"Dini Seel ä chli lo bambala la" *
# ... dir öpis gönne
und chli Fröid am Läbe ha.
# D Seel ä chli lo bambala la.
# Das muess jetz sii.
Ich möchte Sie, geschätzte
Absolventinnen und Absolventen,
jetzt ganz herzlich
zu dieser Feier begrüssen.
Ich möchte die vier Absolventen
jetzt auf die Bühne bitten.
* Applaus *
Insgesamt
sind vier Kandidaten angetreten.
Dieses Jahr
haben alle vier bestanden.
Auf dem Lehrbetrieb
von Markus Ramser in Illhart
hat Tesfu Adanom seine Ausbildung
erfolgreich abgeschlossen.
* Applaus *
Herzliche Gratulation.
Alles Gute. Vielen Dank.
Ich möchte die 76 erfolgreichen
Kandidaten auf die Bühne bitten.
Ah, ja, hier.
Ja, also. Schau hier.
4,2 hat er im Schnitt.
Das ist der Durchschnitt.
4,2?
- Ja.
Trotz einer 2,5
in der theoretischen Prüfung,
im praktischen Teil
hat Tesfu alles wettgemacht.
Ja, ja.
* Fröhliche Klänge *
Ich bin zufrieden.
Man ist erleichtert.
Du hast viel riskiert.
Ich habe etwas probiert.
Ich war von Anfang an überzeugt.
Wir haben immer gesagt:
"Wir haben zwei Jahre Zeit."
Und es ist aufgegangen.
Dieses Papier
ist für ihn sehr viel wert.
Er ist sich dessen nicht bewusst.
Würde er es wieder machen?
Ich würde es immer wieder machen.
Ich bin immer da für Leute,
die das wünschen.
Ich würde nur sagen,
andere sollen es auch probieren.
Es glückt anderen sicher auch.
Aber es braucht Geduld
und v.a. viel ...
... Aufbauarbeit mit ihnen.
Es geht
ein bisschen ins Menschliche.
Emmi und Markus laden zum Essen ein.
Hoi, Tesfu.
- Hallo.
Hoi, Urs.
Auch Emmi ist erleichtert.
Sehr froh, sogar.
Ein grosser Stein
fällt mir vom Herzen.
Markus hat sich einfach Zeit
genommen. Das musste er auch.
Ohne das hätte es nicht geklappt.
Seine Initiative
war nicht immer riesig.
Würdest du es nochmals machen?
Ich persönlich nicht, nein.
Nein.
Weil einfach ...
Alle Umstände,
die damit verbunden sind,
mit seiner Frau usw., wo er halt
auch keine Unterstützung hatte,
es ist schwierig.
Und wir haben jetzt einfach viel
investiert, einfach wegen Tesfu.
Wir mögen Tesfu.
Er ist seit drei Jahren bei uns.
Für uns war es schön heute. Aber ...
Ja, er gehört
jetzt einfach zu unserer Familie,
deshalb
sorgen wir auch immer für ihn
und wollen das Beste für ihn.
Aber wenn sie nicht will,
dann soll sie gehen.
Heute ist kein Tag zum Grübeln.
Alle freuen über Tesfus Erfolg.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Vier Monate später:
Tesfu arbeitet
nach wie vor auf dem Hof,
aber seine private Situation
hat sich grundlegend verändert.
Ein paar Wochen nach seiner
erfolgreichen Abschlussprüfung
ist Merhawit gegangen und hat
Töchterchen Salem mitgenommen.
Niemand weiss,
was genau geschehen ist.
Nun müssen sich die Behörden
mit dem gescheiterten Familiennachzug
befassen.
Du willst nichts sagen?
- Ich will nicht.
Markus, kannst du sagen,
wie die Situation jetzt ist?
Kannst du es sagen?
Ich will auch nichts sagen.
Es gibt auch nicht viel zu sagen.
Markus hat alles versucht,
und konnte es doch nicht richten.
Und Tesfu steht zwischen zwei Kultu-
ren und versteht die Welt nicht mehr.
Ob er seine Tochter wiedersehen darf,
ist völlig offen.
Wieder hilft Markus, wo er kann.
Und wieder ist Tesfu froh darum.
Allen kulturellen Differenzen
zum Trotz:
Markus ist und bleibt
wie ein Vater für ihn.